okay
welcome everyone to the ddps
seminar today uh before we introduce our
invited speaker
let's go over some rules and logistics
uh first of all please mute yourself uh
during the talk
unless you have questions if you have
questions you are welcome to admit
yourself and ask those
questions otherwise please use ch chat
room
to post your questions so that we can
address that
in q a session at the end second no
classified discussion is allowed
allowed so please watch out and finally
the talk today will be recorded and
uploaded
in our youtube channel um that's about
it now let me introduce our speaker
today
um it is a great honor to host
today's speaker george kanyadakis
who is a professor in the department of
applied mathematics at brown university
i do not think that he needs any
introduction because
he is an emerging star in the field of
machine learning-based physical
simulations these days
for example he has coined the word pin
which stands for physics-informed neural
network
he is also currently holding a visiting
professor and senior lecturer
position at mit he has earned
numerous awards in computational
mechanics
for example he is a recipient of the
siam acm
prize on computational science and
engineering in 2021
the alexander von humboldt award in 2017
the siam ralph kleinman award in 2015
the tinsley odin medal in 2013
and the cfd awards in 2077
by the us association in computational
mechanics
moreover i think his hg index and
citation numbers
clearly shows how influential he is in
computational mechanics and data-driven
physical simulation community
these days his age index now is
100 110 and his work has been cited over
56 000 times uh
as of now today professor kanya dakis
will present approximating functions
functionals and operators using deep
neural networks
for diverse applications which is one of
the emerging
topics in machine learning based
physical simulation community
so please enjoy and expect a wonderful
talk from george now without further ado
let me pass the button to
professor kanyadakis by asking one
random question
just to set the stage somewhat informal
for both speakers and audiences uh
today's random question is
since it is today uh the friday today um
what is your favorite things to do
during weekend other than
research after answering these questions
you you can move on to
the actual business today professor oh
that's a good that's a good
question i like i love the english
premiership so i'm a
fanatic chelsea fun so i don't miss any
chelsea
games in england and uh one of my
students
his wife has become now the lawyer for
liverpool
so i'm looking forward for the pandemic
to end so that i can get vip
for a game between liverpool and chelsea
in west london
there's a big game coming good luck
champions
that's right yeah yes thank you i know i
know there are
a lot of and people in academia uh
love soccer so so
um thank you very much uh for the
invitation uh
uh i would like to to start with uh
offering this coffee this virtual coffee
um
i work with la vision i will explain a
little later what
uh this comp this company is a german
company that
does a visualization for formula one for
a lot of industrial problems uh also for
tour de france they they uh they do
visualizations
of people in the bike and so on so they
um i run into them i'll show you the
application later
but uh we just completed the paper it's
paid the papers already published in the
general fluid mechanics
and the reason i show this is in in my
cover slide is to demonstrate that what
pins and other um neural network based
numerical methods we develop in my group
are not supposed to be replacement
of existing solvers which are very good
but
rather to tackle problems real
life problems like you guys have which
are not
cannot be solved with current
technologies any technologies for
example
here uh the vision gave me 3d
data of cour of of this was always
at the back of my mind my big research
question how fast the aroma of my
espresso
hits my nose and i asked them to do
experiments for me
and they gave me this lyrium photography
they use six different cameras
and get a 3d visualization sorry here
you see only part of it
and of course the question i wanted to
answer always was the velocity field
over my espresso coffee mug and what's
the pressure at the same time can i
having this nobody will set up the
problem
for me not boundary conditions not
reynolds number not rayleigh number not
prawn number
just the temperature in the in the
environment and
uh the geometry of the of the cap and
these pictures that you see can i infer
the velocity in 3d and time
and the pressure from that i think it's
a
you agree with me that it's an ill post
problem cannot be answered easily
and this is really uh what i want to
tell you about but of course this
involves function approximation
this is what all neural networks are
based on universal function
approximations
and of course 100 000 papers were
published
last year on functional approximation
what i want to spend most of two-thirds
of my time today to tell you about
functional especially operator
approximation and depot net which is a
the recent
work we published in in nature
machine intelligence and which deepmind
wrote two pages about depot net i'll
tell you why
so let me just say that i am one of you
i am an employee of pnnl one-third of my
salary in the last 10 years comes from
pnnl
and i punch time cards like you uh he
i'm a director also of this mimics
center i don't know if i think lawrence
lieberman doesn't have one
there are three centers like the oe
centers
argon has one and i think university of
austin took texas at austin have another
one but
we are we established this was the first
physics inform uh learning machine
center that we started over four years
ago the actually the proposal was six
years ago
uh i think still the largest coordinated
effort on this and we have um
computer scientists we have uh
application scientists
and physicists and mathematicians as
part of the center
and but the the virtual or physical base
is
pacific's north northwest national lab
and that's why i'm affiliated with them
and so i'm a director
of this center as a pnnl employee
my own group is called crunch which is
the home of
of pins and machine learning plus x and
we started this long time ago so
as i said i want to talk about two
things
i think my student parish pedicares gave
a talk in your group he may have spoken
about
pins that was part of his thesis along
with other people
a few years ago and i'll talk about pins
uh some applications uh and that is when
you have some data and some and some
physics depot net
i would work is a as i said it's the
operator level we regress operators and
functionals
and it could work with when you have a
lots of data and no physics at all
you can work for a black box like these
very complicated systems
that you guys have to work with um
i could represent a a whole digital twin
of a power plant for example
the depot net itself or a bunch of
deponents so a deeponet is much
broader concept uh just a quick thing on
on on pins
and i just have to say that this was
this work was done 2016
uh it took us almost four years this was
published in 2019 because
everybody was uh rejecting our papers
including our friends who were
recommending our friends
as uh as
reviewers and they were rejecting the
paper now not only this is the most
downloaded paper in general
computational physics if you look at the
most downloaded papers in general
computational physics
to the top 20 15 of them are associated
with my group
either 10 of them from my group and the
other five is from my students
so that of course the pin combines uh
it's a it's a composite neural network
it's it's a standard neural network
you try to find you as a function of x
and t and of course that's the data part
uh the math for this is very simple even
computer scientists can understand it
sorry if there's any computer scientist
in the audience but it's basically least
squares uh
for regression and you just minimize
that and and uh
and and you get an answer for physics in
form
of course here you need about 10 000
measurements to get this function you
you don't have those measurements
instead what you have is
lots of physics some physics
parameterized physics like for example a
non-linear
strategy equation here parameterized
i don't need to know exactly the
equation
and i have these operators which i will
use this i will use
automatic differentiation the same way
that i prop i i
propagate jacobians
the errors and jacobians i compute
jacobians i will use the same automatic
differentiation to compute
the first derivative secondary vectors
and so on so
this will give me another function to
minimize namely the residual f here will
be the residual
which where i will evaluate at random
points and the domain how many points
nf points i evaluate that residual and i
will penalize it to be
zero then i take the data part which is
this part here
i take the physics part which is this
part here i can weight them
i can have weights lambda data and
lambda physics here
and i form a loss function which can
minimize using adam and then lbfgs and
so on
just the standard of the shelf
off-the-shelf optimizers
the method is very simple um
and and and i tell my colleagues even
professors can now program this stuff
that's why they're it's very popular not
because sophisticated
here for example for the burgers
equation you can see with
in tensorflow this is defining the left
part
this is defining the physics take the
derivatives with the
automatic differentiation and we form
these
now in this domain you can see here i
don't have boundary conditions
here i can have gaps so this is where my
data is this this crosses of the data
when i have where i compute the residual
will be these random points
right so like 10 minutes later high
school student if you give him this
equation or here
i can produce this solution and this is
a real case actually i've done that with
high school students
they know how to obtain solutions like
that of
this religion equation non-linear
scientific equation because it's very
very simple
okay so here's an extension which is
very important
uh recently we published a paper called
parallel pins how you can do
pins in parallel and you use the domain
decomposition
why i like this is because it's also
space
time decomposition so i look at the same
problem as before
so the we never discretize x we never
discretize t
both are continuous coordinates but i
can divide that domain into two parts
the blue c and the beautiful dolphin
i don't need to do that here but you can
imagine if you have the donations if you
have
any other moving parts in a domain
moving domains sliding domains or
rotated domains rotating domains you may
want to do that
or you may want to do that to for
multi-scale multiphysics problems
or you may want to do that because you
want to do to exploit parallelism
so for this particular case for the same
equation
we define two domains one and two
and then we define here two neural
networks so i can change the number of
new
there they i map one neural network per
gpu
okay so you can see now i have different
activation functions in one place than
the other
a different size of network and so on so
i have the extended pin x stands for
extended
gives you tremendous flexibility both
computational
but also physical from a physical
modeling point of view from me
from domains and so on now what's the
magic you say how would you because we
have something else called shipping
at the shipping we're basically using um
the discontinuous galerkin formula for
flux is to penalize fluxes
at this red boundary well
the x pin is actually much simpler it
takes only one line to go from pin
to x pin because the only thing you
penalize
at this residual is this f the residual
at minus outside the the dolphin
f inside the dolphin you take this
residual
along the red boundary and you penalize
without some constant lambda
okay so the only and of course the
residual has to be continuous because
the residual has to be zero
so this extends to any type of pd's
and all these and as you can see here
this
is a non-convex domain it's an arbitrary
domain you cannot take derivatives as
you can see here
but also i have uh decomposed space time
so i have parallelism space paralleling
time and tremendous flexibility
and the solutions are looked pretty
pretty good actually so we have done
this for shocks
for navier stokes with lots of different
applications in this in this paper
but this is just one example to show you
the flexibility of this
just going back to a couple of years ago
we
last year actually we published this
paper this work done a few years ago
where we were trying to solve this
inverse problem like the coffee i showed
you
and so so like for the coffee example
i will take the temperature here and
then i have the navier stokes which i
penalized all this is computed with that
automatic differentiation
and then i can in this example in
science we said okay
if i give you a video in this arbitrary
cut out behind the cylinder can you find
uh
of a scalar a passive scalar can you
find the velocity and the pressure
and indeed you can find time dependent
velocity fields and
and pressure fields um without any pain
without solving for example
a explicit poisson equation for pressure
and you can do you can do it to compute
forces and so on
um and just refer to the paid to the to
the science paper or the archive
but this is what brought me to la vision
the company that i like now
they are interested in buying their
patents that's why i'm kind of
friends with them but this is this is
one of our collaborators
his name is thomas burke he's one of the
people who work for la vision
it's a company in get again germany so
he was puffing
as you can see here this is lyrium
photography with it with and without a
mask and
then we took that from there we took
these pictures from the video from
youtube video
and we compute it we quantify the
velocity and the pressure field around
his um
uh his nose down here
i had the movie but i don't know why
this movie cannot play but but you can
see down here
i have a path of the pressure uh
with um without the mask and then with
the mask we also have the velocity field
around his nose
uh the same thing applies here for the
for the coffee that i show you namely
um what we are given is something like
that we can reconstruct
we're giving actually temperature
gradients or density gradients
we can reconstruct this we assume a
business approximation for
that is valid we don't know the railing
number or any other properties
and we come we can see you can you can
match the you can get the velocity and
the pressure here
this is 2d slices but actually the 3d
uh people didn't believe us that this
velocity is actually pretty fast 0.4
meters per
second so they did the piv experiments
independently
it's in the jfm paper which is uh here
we also have a paper that will come out
this month in nature
physics reviews on physics informed
learning and we have these nice
you can see the mags have now actually
neural networks
we don't sell them we give them for free
so anyway uh take my word for it you can
actually compute this very accurately
the piv
independent measurements show that
indeed the maximum velocity is 0.4
meters per second which was surprising
to me
we just filed another patent on aiv
artificial intelligence fellow symmetry
blood is a very uh dense uh
suspension of red blood cells forty
percent amount of cream for example
in humans so here we're looking at um
blood in micro devices uh
is because we're interested in what
happens in the blood in this microanus
never mind that
the point is that can you quantify the
stresses
in these vessels uh wall shear stresses
and pressure just using
this type of visualizations and also can
you reconstruct 3d fields from 2d fields
we can do simulations and we can do
benchmarks because it's not very easy to
visualize this very as you can see here
these are real data very opaque so
anyway we we
came up with an idea of how we can
reconstruct the whole 3d field we can
satisfy the important
boundary conditions here we can go very
close right at the wall and therefore we
can compute the
all shear stresses which is right the
slope here very important unlike
anything
in the literature levision is interested
in this technology now
uh the methods are agnostic to
applications
here we pose a kind of
difficult problem to solve with any
method you could
solve it but it's a it's the following
question
can you find how many holes what is the
size of the hole
in a specimen in in a solid
the solid could be hyperelastic like a
rubber could be a metal
or any material in fact if you have
only measurements of displacements as
you pull this apart
in this biaxial tension so i only have
measurements of displacement not
stresses at all
and i'm asking the question can you
infer all the all the
the mechanics of this and also find
where the hole is
okay so we can parametrize this with one
or two parameters or if you do splines
you can parametrize or you can have a
neural network that parameterize the
geometry
here i show one type of equations that
you will bring in here
into the physical part of the neural
network and the answer is yes you can
very quickly starting from the wrong
answer you can see i start down here
the answer is over there and you can
comp you can find if there's a hole how
big is the hole where's the orientation
of the hole and so on so you can imagine
that that's
very important for materials for design
design designing materials with
lightweight materials where you make
holes and so on
it's the ultimate invest problem we have
done that for metals we have done
any plasticity we have done in all
regimes of
work with some people from this is a
real test real data
this was a a darpa hackathon about a
dozen teams
the problem is as follows there is a
crack a surface crack here this is a
nickel
alloy i think and
and there's a ultrasound that hits this
surface crack the real data here is on
the left
and the questions can you characterize
fully the crack
where it is what's the size and so on
now
uh out of the 12 teams 11 teams
failed because they said they didn't
have enough data
we actually use only 10 of the data we
use 10 percent of the data from the
ultrasound
and we match the data first
we also had as you can see we put the
physics in here
so we put this is now my residual trend
but c
here is a function of x and y that's the
speed of sound
which of course is not constant if you
have a crack or any microstructure
inside the material
so here i can show you what an
independent neural network
which represented this unknown function
c we found that
we discover c if you discard c then you
can have of course the crack
this this here on the right shows that
pins can
match the real data now one of the key
so one there are two
reasons why we were the only ones who
could do this problem we wrote the paper
with the air force people who who write
paterson who supply this data
one is that uh you will use the physics
that's why we don't need a lot of
data but the data is noisy so we use so
you get a lot of local minima so so your
your adam optimizer will get stuck
somewhere
so what we develop is um you may have
seen some
some work we've done on adaptive
activation functions we parameterize the
activation functions
so every neuron can fire in at its own
rate now every neuron has an extra
parameter
or you can have a whole layer having one
parameter and so on so those parameters
can be found by the data
we prove a theorem that shows that if
you do that
then you guarantee that you will not
trap you'll not get trapped into bad
minima we don't guarantee you'll get a
global minimum but we guarantee that we
can
you will not never get trapped in in bad
minimum and that was the key as i said
theoretical work that led to
adaptive activation functions i'm not
talking about i'm not going to talk
about
all this alphabet of pins there are
several review papers we're writing and
so on
but i think this paper in um which will
appear this month in nature physics
reviews
have a lot about it but uh we're solving
stochastic pds using guns for example
non-local problems and fractional um
these variational problems basically you
can have instead of
you can have um the equivalent of what
we what i developed in
my phd this is 30 years ago the spectral
element method
on arbitrary arbitrary domains and so on
and i already
told you about the x pins there's a
library deep xd that you can download
and so on but what i want to
talk about for the rest of
my talk is this uh you answer can you
see a movie
i don't know if you can see a movie
because it's a big movie
i can see a movie yeah okay so this is a
real destroyer
from the navy this is a project i did
for the navy with them
my mit colleagues this is a destroyer dx
going through uh a very rough seas
c state 8 20 meters it's supposed to be
autonomous
and so of course you're interested to
find out
for this excitation the stochastic
elevation of the sea
uh this is north of north atlantic
specific spectrum in the west there's a
different spectrum
so the question is how do you find the
motion you have to use the cfd
simulation simulate the whole thing
flow structure interaction free surfaces
viscosity uh
six degrees of freedom complex geometry
takes
it takes uh at least one week on a
parallel computer to do a simulation
like that using open foam for example so
so i didn't do that at brown because
brown students are not patient or
so i did this with mit students so after
three months of training
we get enough data differences states
and so on
and we just use a uh a simple
uh so so what we wanted is basically to
approximate the functional the function
will be
the degrees of the motion of the of of
the uh
of this destroyer six degrees of freedom
or three degrees of freedom depending on
as a function of time given a stochastic
excitation so
so basically what we're talking about
here is a map from a stochastic
excitation of the c elevation
to map to to as an output will be this
functional which will be
um a functions of time here
of six degrees of freedom first of all i
was interested i would i was interested
you know
and applied math i'm interested in
theory can you actually do that
um and and have some guarantees and i
found this
dual theorem by chen and chen back in
about the same time that the universal
theorem of approximation a couple of
years later
by say pengo and other people was
developed and indeed he showed that
there is that neural networks just a
standard neural network
in fact can approximate a functional
f of u in one or multiple dimensions so
then
using that then you can just go and take
any you can take any rnn or lstm or gre
or
any any neural network that has some
memory and
train it using this data and now this is
the input here
two different inputs and this will be an
output corresponding to one of the
stochastic inputs you can see the inputs
are
stochastic the outputs are stochastic so
if you train this takes some time to
train
it but basically you can compute you can
compute in
0.1 seconds of the dynamics
of of the destroyer instead of one week
and you can see the accuracy is very
good there's a little bit of discrepancy
here compared to the
one week cfd but obviously you can
improve that
so there's enough expressivity uh
not just we didn't use a as i said we
use an lstm
here you could use a a deeper arrest net
or something else maybe
so that leads me to deponet which is a
generalization of what i just told you
so i i was interested to see
uh can i find can i can i regress
operators any type of operators
operators which will be
pds operators will which will be
integrals
laplace transforms uh fractional
operators stochastic operators and so on
okay so this is as i said this this
paper that was published
recently uh so you say well what's the
big deal well
there is mathematically of course
there's a big deal because you go from a
finite
space when you go when you ma when you
regress a function data in data out
to an add a infinite dimensional space
at the input to an infinite dimensional
space at the output
and and here i'm thinking about any
operator
it has to be a continuous operator later
i'll
talk about also non-continuous operator
they have to be in a compact space
actually most of the operators i will
show you is the
non-compact space in including laplace
transforms for for example
uh we so it could be a dynamic system
it could be a system that we don't know
anything about the governing equations
as long as we know
x of t and y of t and
so i probe a system uh with
x of t some excitation force i record
the
response eventually i will learn that
system no matter what the
how complicated the system is could be a
biological system a social system
or a system of systems okay so now the
question that we pose is can we learn
operators
via neural networks how are they
theoretical guarantees and here
again to our rescue kane chen and chen
who two years later proved the same
theorem this this theorem
nobody knew about it when i discovered
it actually um
uh this is a professor uh
at fudan university and he wrote to me
he's 87 years old now to thank me that i
discovered his theorem
but anyway he showed that for just like
the previous theme for
even using it that the proof is for a
single layer
okay using a single layer g is the
non-linear
continuous operator u is the input which
will be
uh here you would be a function of x
it lives in a space v the input space
which is a compact space
okay and now the output will be g of u
so you map u to g of u
at y so y is the output space
so basically it shows that uh this
theorem tells you that yes
neural networks actually two neural
networks
you can see i have a sigma here and i
have another sigma here they don't have
to be the same activation functions
but this is one neural network and this
is another neural network
so they said that this could actually
approximate
any function there's actually just
theoretical work
okay so uh what we did is to actually
take this
formula and map it into different neural
networks i will
talk about this one here on the right
so there's a branch associated with this
and you can see this is just this neural
network here
and then there's a trunk which
associated with the output
and this is this neural network here so
we have continuous inputs
continuous outputs and that so we map
from an infinite dimensional space to an
infinite vessel space
this is for a single layer so it's not
very expressive and in fact it suffers
from the case of dimensionality because
we're trying to train operators you need
a lot of data
so what we did is we extend the theorem
of to
arbitrary deep neural networks so now we
replace this with
some neural network approximations of
the trunk and the branch
we have the proof in the 60 page paper
in this uh in the um appendix here
but i'm not going to present it here so
so
this is what we're talking about we're
talking about mapping g
from u to g of u so we'll do that by
training taking lots of functions record
the output
and then eventually after we learn g
given a new
unseen data unseen function can we
look at the output of outputs i can have
one excitation with multiple outputs
right so
so this this sketch here show you
approximately what's happening in
practice
in the this is the input space i use
like 100 points per function in the
output space i only need to observe at
one or two points which is good thing
because that's the output is basically
the simulated data or experiments
uh that will that's that's that's where
the cost is right here
so i'm going to demonstrate this with a
very simple example
let's say we want to learn this operator
the linear operator of the integral from
zero to x
okay x could be from zero to one we also
did from zero to infinity we did all
laplace transforms
so you take 10 000 functions from some
distribution v that will be the input
space
here my this my input space is a gauss
random field
now gas random field does not give you a
compactness so i evaluate the theorem
uh and i use 100 sensors to represent
discretely these inputs now how you
represent the
the input space is important i will show
you an example but the important thing
here is that i only need
s to be evaluated at the sink at a
certain point
x star for one function only one point
of course axis leaves from zero to one
so i can have a million points here
but it turns out that you only need one
which is very very important
that has to has since since then now we
have theory
i will talk about that if i have at the
end uh i have a
time so but what you see here is the
mean square error for training and the
testing there's a number of iterations
we go down to the minus five which is
pretty good accuracy
and this is the neural network i show
you it shows the difference between the
training and the testing area is very
small
as opposed to using other neural
networks where the generalization error
here
would be very large so this type of
neural network the deponet
generalizes well uh surprisingly
here's a system where i have two outputs
s1 and s2 and i have one excitation
as an input this is still all these but
what we notice is that
the tiponet learns exponentially fast if
you look at the
error here generalization or training
versus the training data you see this is
an exponential fast
curve eventually it saturates the
network is small enough
it's not expressive enough so we go back
to
one over square root of n let's say
convergence algebraic convergence
here's a little better and so on but as
i make
the network larger in width for example
this transition point this one here
moves to the right
so it seems that there's a magic network
out there
that that would be expressive enough
so this network would learn operators
the operator here is the system of
of two non-linear audis you can learn
that exponentially fast which is of
course
a great advantage and to to see
in practice so we have now theory as i
said that that explains this exponential
convergence
now we wanted to do something more fancy
i i for those of you who have followed
some of my work i the last 10 years i
work a lot on fractional differential
equations because i found them
i found the integer ones really really
boring to tell you the truth
and uh and and and fractional
differential apparatus are very
expressive just like
deep neural networks so here we wanted
to know
can you can can we train deponent to
learn a
caputo fractional derivative of course
we know the formulas and so on so
just like the integral uh the caputo
fraction derivative is a little tricky
because it has a singular kernel
as you can see here but the answer is
yes we can learn we can learn how to do
that
it would be very important what the
space v
of inputs is and this plot here is
supposed to show you
the mean square error there's a number
of iterations for different spaces v
grf which i used before is this however
if i
represent with some spectral bases
something we discovered about 10 years
ago
is a new class of orthogonal
polyfractionomials
polynomials with with fractional orders
which have recurrent formulas
if we do that we we get really two
orders of magnitude so
how uh improving so how do you do how
how do you get
how do you express the input is very
important to get good accuracy i will
skip a lot of
stuff here we have we can learn
stochastic pds
um the trajectories i will
talk about a couple of physical examples
and then i will take questions
so you all know what
tiny bubbles are and big bubbles and so
on
so um for the continuum if you have
relatively large bubbles there is uh
back from
lord rayleigh there's an equation that
uh
this type of equation that if you start
with it with a bubble like that
this equation given a pressure
difference delta p which is here
it can tell you how r of t
increases of course i want to
train deponent to learn this operator
this non-linear operator
okay this is just a i don't use any math
here i only use the math to generate
data to train my network
after i train my network i give it a new
pressure difference
and i want to predict r as a function of
time
okay so the pressure difference is the
input
the function the time will be the input
to the trunk net
and and we'll get out the radius
as a function of time for given delta p
okay so so in fact we represent the
uh function here so here's the results
you can see that i can have arbitrary
pressure distributions like this
and then the dynamics of the bubbles
this is unseen data this is testing
it's not trivial the you have very fast
oscillations the bubble
breathes like that oscillates and then
and then because of viscosity
it decays and so on so we are able to
cop to capture the dynamics depot net
in point one second again point one
second no matter what is point one
second
and no matter how difficult the problem
is it will predict the correct dynamics
for us in data of course we're more
ambitious
we're interested to know what happens if
you have a really tiny bubble
a nano bubble down to nucleation and the
bubble rises and becomes like that
uh of course the continuum regime these
equations
are not valid below about one micron
and so so we wanted to feed the opponent
with
two types of data uh continuum data
would generate from
this equation by the way you could have
video if you have a video
you can replace the equation with video
data and you use the cnn for the
for the for the branch and then we do
dpd
dpds like stochastic molecular dynamics
if you like
but coarse-grained molecular dynamics
that can do these tiny bubble
simulations
and um here we show that indeed we can
do this
uh but i want to show you this result
that
shows that depot net which was trained
using
continuum data here uh molecular data
here
can give you great answers in all three
regimes
this is the continuum regime this is the
stochastic regime
optimistic regime and this is right here
there's an overlap
of data now in doing so i avoided any
handshaking i just
fed the depot net with data
in the in this overlap region i gave it
both continuum data
and md data molecular dynamics data this
is
molecular data here is continuum data
so we get good answers it turns out that
you cannot distinguish from the
running now this has again takes point
one seconds
uh to to to to in this regime
it's it's fast to to of course to solve
this ld with matlab
but to to simulate this uh takes about
one day
because it's molecular dynamic
simulation so now everything is 0.1
seconds
so so now given the initial radius
and delta p you can produce the r of t
in any regime from the nano bubble to
the milli bubble
to the bigger bubble and i will finish
with this um
with this example which is a hypersonic
flows it's a current project we have
with darpa we're looking at both at
inviscid and viscous we're looking at
the case where we have um
mach number eight to ten and the air
dissociates
the big bottleneck as you can appreciate
here
is the chemistry so we have five species
that we need to track so what we did
with deeponet is to learn the chemistry
given velocity and temperature in these
equations here
some data we can get all the chemistry
all the species here
on the evolution of the species and the
initial conditions and so on
so we were able to beat the cfd solder a
hundred thousand times
um because the time step there's no
restrictions in timestamp and there's uh
so i want to show you some applications
with the euler with the inviscid case
dynamics this is
a case now we have three species still
non-equilibrium chemistry
and here we use uh a code by my
colleague chinguan shu
who has this best codes for we know
especially and also
including non-equilibrium chemistry that
guarantees uh positivity
uh and um and and and what we are trying
to do is to
uh given some arbitrary initial
conditions for the pressure let's say
and pressure ratio the ratio could be
five to a thousand
so i take 100 trajectories
from the inner code to train my depot
net
and then 50 trajectories for testing and
you can see
here i have multiple deponents i could
have one but i want to make it modular
in a plug-and-play mode so you can see
here given initial conditions for
n2 i can predict any time what is
and and space what is the distribution
of that
of all the species and also the
velocities so indeed
given uh so so what i'm changing is the
basically the initial condition
and i parameterize with the eta here and
the sharpness of the riemann problem
gives me different solutions
so you can see here i start with the
black lines as initial conditions
and after some time i target specific
time
after some time you can see here for
example the velocity i start with zero
i get this velocity the deponent gives
you that in point one seconds
with accuracy ten to the minus five and
you can see here training and testing
is pretty good and this is my last slide
i think this is the ultimate uh
application of depot net
uh you have not seen this yet because we
haven't published it
uh so what do we have here let's start
with the left
here we're looking at a hypersonic
boundary layer
and these are pressure transducers who
have discrete
measurements of pressure on
on the um plate
by pre-training a depot net
uh we can if and and we use the inverse
deponent
we can infer what is the
free stream disturbance the upstream
boundary condition okay
now having the
disturb these disturbances plus these
pressure transducers downstream
we can reconstruct in space-time the 3d
field
using the forward deponent okay and as
you can see here
on the right in the movie um
we just we now have a 3d field and we
have the initial conditions and so on so
this is work with uh
johns hopkins university uh charles
miller and tamar zaki
so this takes about 0.1 second this
takes 1.1 second of course after
you do the expensive offline training so
just want to summarize um we
in the last three years we've been
working on this depot net and we
in the paper i mentioned in nature we
have 16 different applications for
pdes stochastic pds explicit operators
like integration
differentiation and so on one of the
questions was
you know what happens if you if you have
a lot of inputs
and you want to reduce the accuracy to
increase the accuracy reduce the error
by a factor of two
would would you have the curse of
dimensionality in the in approximating
this general non-linear operators and
and in this paper is up
this paper is 116 pages long it's all
theory
by sid misrat
i'm a etho there but i didn't really do
anything uh substantial they
the graduate student did most of the
work with sid misra
they took our paper and they put a
strong theoretical foundation behind it
uh they explain
the exponential convergence i talked and
talked to you about the extended
uh deponent to non-compact why we're
getting so good results with non-compact
uh
input spaces so and also
uh we talked about continuous operators
but the
operator i show you for the multi-scale
problem of of bubbles it was
actually a discontinuous operator so so
they have also
extended this to measurable operators
not necessarily continuous operators
and some other and they have lots of um
other theorems including how you need to
sample
for example they found that it
generalized well and also
in the input space it's it's good enough
to do a random sampling
you don't need to do any better that's
almost close to optimum
i'll finish with the statement from this
this was a two-page uh article as i said
by deep
by deepmind i didn't know that they
would would do that and they
they published also this in in nature
and they said that the deeponet is
is very fast and we can read here that
can approximate
um it can be trained using both
experimental and
simulation data and different fidelities
and also
uh you can you can model dynamics of of
complex systems
where no analytical descriptions exist
and that actually that was my
original motivation for doing that we
use here math just to and the pds just
to generate data
but since then we have um model many
complex systems for example i
recently work with nrel and
from doe and we model using deeponet we
model a
thermal battery called thermal battery
using only as an input
uh the irradiance cloud coverage
and so uh and and also the temperature
the ambient temperature and then the uh
we can predict the state of the charge
uh downstream of the rankine cycle
at the output now let me just think
here also all the my sponsors as a new
murie we
received recently from afrsr have some
pretty good collaborators
on the theory side from caltech
from stanford uh we are looking at the
hypersonic problem so zarbel farhat is
there
and we're looking at metal learning and
uh
some of my collaborators from university
of utah where in computer science will
be
part of it so uh i think with this i
would like to um
stop and and take questions
thank you so much it was wonderful talk
um
okay let's have a q and a session
we do have a question one question in
chat room
by um this oh oh my goodness
by uh vincenzo he asked
can you comment on the applicability of
the no
freelance theorem to keep on add
deponent is expensive it's expensive to
remember i told you
um but it wasn't exactly the point but
the deponent is expensive offline
it takes it takes uh time and effort and
and dedication
from to to train it uh but of course uh
when you um you use it for prediction
and inference
uh it as fast as your laptop no matter
how big how difficult the problem is 3d
1d
law i mean that's so so uh because you
you basically interpolate or extrapolate
um
so so there's there is uh
we don't violate the free lunch uh uh
theorem
okay thank you well can you can you give
us um
you know follow-on questions can you
give us some sense of how expensive the
training phase is for the deep owner
yeah so so uh i can tell you because we
just introduced in this
last example which i show you
we're doing this psc parabolized
stability equations and
that's how we generate the data because
we want to see if deponent can do
stability analysis
and so we generate data using a spectral
code
and the cost for generating the data
which was i think about 50
snapshots or of the order of 100 let's
say 100
that's how expensive was the training of
deponet
however compare now the spectral code
trying to predict new disturbances
uh comp to the um to deponent
uh making new inferences uh deponent
beat spec the spectral code
i'm a spectral guy so i can i can talk
about that
uh 10 to the fifth so the speed up was
10 to the 5th in the inference
so it's basically real time yep very
nice
okay the following question next
question
by craig he said wow
uh has this been applied together very
very good question very very good
question because that's where the uh
that's where the interest and the so i'm
working currently with
pnml i don't know if you know ruby ruby
young
she is in charge she's the chief
scientist of arm
for doe so uh she loves the stuff so
we're trying to uh
create digital twins for uh different
aspects of
of weather prediction including what's
going on in the midwest
and also um using all the assets from uh
from arm all the radars and so on for
cloud parameterization and so on so but
but the answer to your question is not
yet but
uh there is great interest from within
doe
and i hope other people as it depends on
what aspect of the weather you're
looking at but i think that
there's great potential here yeah okay
thank you um the next question um by
wrong pay is there any correlation
between the number of
governing equations and the number of
layers in neural math
oh for pins you mean or um
yeah yeah yeah i mean assuming that
that the multiphysics problems the
number of equations leads to
multiple to stiff problems and
then you need a deeper
neural network to be more expressive but
if if you saw my if you saw the the
title of my murie that was
one of the questions we also tried to
address
systematically the question of metal
learning
so looking at the type of a pd parabolic
hyperbolic and so on and the type of
multiphysics can you design neural
networks which are optimum
uh in terms of accuracy uh you know it
depends on what
and we use reforms for learning
techniques to do meta learning which is
the answer that question uh every
anything else i would say
is kind of like empirical and uh and
um depend on the postdoc they do
different things
there are certain
trade secrets but we actually write them
in the paper
so so but but there's um
typically we we go with like 10 layers
if you want a number
10 layers for uh for these multiphysics
um problems thank you uh rupen also
interested in seeing again the slide for
you know the slide with the poison
equations
and which was an equation it was the
first part the pins or the um
i believe so uh
he believed that you know it was skipped
during the talk
um but he believed yeah i know i know i
think he's talking about the
stochastic um right
yeah i think it's the stochastic one um
yeah what's your question because i get
lost here i just want to know
what what you learned by neural network
we
we may be doing some similar things so i
want to know what
exactly you are trying to learn what is
your input and output and
maybe also the network
uh yeah that application is um uh the
okay so for the deep one for that was
the depot net right that i was
trying to do the stochastic operator let
me see if i can uh
go back to it
and and basically i was i cannot for
some reason
i got this is frozen um
oh is it closing
yeah but you can hear me right yeah i
can hear you sorry i cannot show you but
but it's basically a stochastic um
a pd with uh stochastic
hydraulic conductivity let's say right
which is a process
it was a five-dimensional process and we
uh
the deponet can learn that operator so
given
any different conductivity we map
the stochastic process which is the
conductivity to the output the
stochastic solution
in six dimensional space
uh in the paper that we are about to
publish we have
also a hundred dimensional space so the
opponent can learn the stochastic
operator
just like it learned so the mapping here
would be from the conductivity which is
a stochastic process
to the output u which is x comma omega
omega is for stochastic right so not
just statistics but we're mapping to
individual trajectories
did i answer your question uh yes you
answer my question
i'm also curious in your input is it
it's just the conductivity or you have
some sample point of the solution you
know
some you know some solution well this is
well deponently deponent at least the
version i show you today
deeponnet is a um supervised learning
right remember when i did the integral
right the very first example
i also have to give values of the
integral at some points
so the answer to your question is yes we
know the solution
at some points for the training period
and then
now we don't have to do that one of my
students uh paris perticarius we gave a
talk
uh i think in your seminar uh recently
they they
um wrote the paper where they combine
pin with
deponet during the training you can put
their physical laws
if you know the physics and you don't
have to to do supervised learning you do
unsupervised learning if you have the if
you know the physics
i believe that the best way to train
operators is to provide some data
and some physics uh and that is the
that's where pins work very well and
that's where you the training is fast
has to do with the more like the
optimization and avoiding local minima
and so on but uh
but the answer to your question is yes
you you provide some data yeah
maybe my my last question is do you
think it's possible to learn
the solution without the sample solution
data
you just learn the solution from the
conductivity
uh it's like unsupervised learning
but in the training you have to do
something there's no there's no
like someone said freelance there's no
magic
either you have to put the the physics
or you have to uh
um uh or you have to uh
to put data or hybrid so
so when you have the physics that's
unsupervised learning actually
yes so so so so what the idea here is i
said we call physics informed deponent
physics the informed deponet you during
the training you have the
physical law so you penalize the
residual i was talking about in the fin
in the pins part
then after you learn the operator you
don't use that physics anymore
because you don't you want to do it fast
right otherwise it becomes
yeah so the other the other thing you
can do
and we did that for darpa because you
know we were flying up the mach number
eight to ten and then say oh yeah but
the guy the programmer said no no i
don't fly at mach number 13
can i use what you you did so i said
well and i need some data so he said i
only have
three data on temperature and two data
on uh on velocity this is real stuff
uh and nothing on the chemistry and uh
how fast can you do it and instead of
0.1
seconds in one second we were able to
actually
use deponet with the new data simulate
the new data
and predict mach number 13 which is way
outside the range of
training yeah that was they call it
extrapolation but
we called out of out of distribution i
think that i saw some uh
uh questions from the uh on the chat i
would like
i'll be happy to uh to answer them if
you're sure if you if you read them to
me yeah uh the next question by uh david
is um does deep-o net typically
require manual extensive feature
transformations for example
transforming time or spatial coordinates
or
special data normalization yeah very
very good question
the um uh we are we're trying to do a
problem with um
seismic data very high frequency data
and uh as you know because of the
spectral bias for example
uh high frequencies would not be favored
so what we did is
uh we um
we include um in the trunk instead of a
time
we put sine omega t sine 10 10 omega t
sine 100 omega t and so on so so we can
do features like that
but just to to answer this question um
we're about to this is the first time i
will say this
to to publish some new work where we
have um
rowdy activation functions activation
functions which have
this let's say the relu the slope
changes depending on the data but also
we put
random fluctuations at the at the um
at the ends or the minus one to one for
the so so this way
basically we put features into the into
the adaptive activation functions
but uh it's a good it's a good point
because
uh for some multi-scale problems when
you have huge disparity in
in temporal or spatial scales both pins
and deponents all neural networks will
have difficulty and you need to do
something special
you're right about that thank you
george the next question by tyler is
have you applied this
to study rare events i'm particularly
thinking of a very
high dimensional system of sde
stochastic differential equations
so it's expensive to get data
simulations and there it is
is really really good question uh i
don't know if you follow the work of
semi-sepsis at mit on dynamical systems
and rare events
he uh and i i'm i'm not actually doing
anything but he
he got a he just got three months ago a
project from darpa
to do exactly that and and and the way
he's
proposing to solving the problem of
uh is to to weigh the output so that
then he samples the right input so he
has some theory to see
like precursors of this type of rare
events
so that will help him to sample
appropriately
the input so that he can see in the
training a lot of rare events
because of the imbalance of data am i am
i answering your question
yeah yeah yeah it it
it is a really interesting problem but
but i think using active learning and
this uh
he has some fancy a acquisition
functions his name is
sepsis s-a-p-s-i-s
yeah i was just just curious if you
thought about that because you know
i think most approaches right now are
like
dealing with importance-based sampling
or kinetic monte carlo
type stuff so yeah i didn't know if
you'd been working on
the deep learning approach for that
yeah as i said he is doing the work he
wanted to do in the context
of deponet because darpa loves the
opponent now so so
so he basically got the grand baser on
the opponent but i think he's he's
making some progress he
hasn't published anything yet okay
the next question by donald after
uh learning a linear operator if you
want to extend it to a non-linear
operator how
effective is transfer learning to extend
a
pre-trained depot net yeah we we have we
have not done it but
i believe it can be done um so the
reason i'm saying that is because we
for some systems um we found that
um we basically i had yeah
if you if you in the in the trunk in the
trunk space
if you put actually you've done
something similar but and i can tell
that it will it will work it's a great
idea so what you do
you put and that relates to the previous
question in the trunk space
together with the coordinates and so on
you put also the linearized
part of the operator that you learn
and then you and then in the branch you
you have new excitations and you can
learn the non-linear part
on top of it i think it can be done
we've done something
similar so that that tells me but but i
cannot guarantee that it will work but i
think
uh it's it's a good idea and i and as i
said
through the trunk you can put the things
that you learned before
uh uh into the network remember there
are two
branches in the trunk right yeah
well this is this is a good crowd i give
a lot of talks
this is a good good uh good relevant
questions
i i guess you have to come back and then
give another talk
okay um well i don't see any more
questions
um so but that doesn't mean um
you cannot ask questions i mean if you
have questions you cannot mute yourself
and
um directly ask a question here
can i ask a question sure sure go ahead
uh so
in your you know introduce your uh your
network for
this continuous operator you use an
example of 100
sensors there so i'm just wondering this
number of sensors
is it a fixed uh hyper parameter you
your neural network uh so so let's let's
say you have trained this your
network with 100 sensors now i have a
new new input function uh
i have let's say 1000 data can i still
use your neural network to get the
uh output for this operator yeah yeah
no it's not a hyper parameter this is
this is just to make it to make things
simple
in fact when i showed the example of the
of the fractional operator i was making
the point that
it's up to you how you represent the
space v the input space the input space
the simplest thing would be take a
interval divide by a hundred and
and you do that that's that's my hundred
so that's but that's not a
hyperparameter you can you can do
in fact you can do arbitrary random
sampling of your input space
or you can represent the input space
with wavelets or you can represent it's
id
with spectral methods or your input
space v
can be a neural network right because
that's a function space
so you can have a neural network that
produces that function that can be
directly
an input to depot net
so so when you train your your network
do you have to specify that
well you have because you take a sum it
was a sum in the in the
theorem you could see the sum over all
the points u x i
of i equals 1 to m m was the number of
sensors so so
so yes you you do have to specify that
but but it doesn't need to be constant
whatever you sample if you sample at a
thousand you put a thousand
it's not a hyper parameter it's it's
like a uh representation of that
space in input space
so i mean the architecture of your
network doesn't depend on that
no no no it does not depend on that now
ah okay i see thank you
yeah okay
um any other questions yeah i have a
question
um go ahead george yeah so in your
recent paper
uh about uh solving a stochastic inverse
problems
um the one you just put on archive i
think in march
uh using a discrete particle observation
um and you use the the variational form
of the kl divergence oh yeah
yeah that was different yeah yeah you
mean right yeah yeah i know it's
different i just wanted to ask you about
that so i think
in that paper you go up to like five
dimensional
up equations is that right
something like that
how high dimensional do you think you
can handle um we need a hundred we have
a hundred actually
in a revised paper similar to it we have
a hundred
but it is it is an issue how to generate
the data but it's uh
[Music]
we did a hundred
above that is a little difficult for
this unless you know
you have you explain the composition of
the functions on but the 100
right so yeah so i'm trying to think
about i mean i know the
inverse problem is one thing and it's
impressive but just particularly
in regards to the forward problem i'm
thinking of
you know what would be the difference or
how would you compare or do you have a
comparison say
of or just thoughts in general about uh
you know using pins for this high
dimensional focal block
uh equation stuff versus say a tensor
terrain
approach in parallel um
um i would say
for the forward if you if you for the
forward problem if you don't have any
data at all i wouldn't i wouldn't use
pins i would use like um i have a paper
where i was using um uh
this um gpr and ganks
like this this cl click this click
approach
uh and i did a hundred thousand
dimensions do you know that paper
i don't have i don't yeah so it's called
if you it's a cisc paper
the um uh science journal
of scientific computing i did a hundred
thousand dimensions
uh using what's called additive kernels
and gp so instead of having of course
a tensor product of all this you can
write um
the kernel as a sum of kernels and of
course
the effective dimensionality obviously
in order to do be able to do that
there's no
you have to find the effective
dimensionality and you find through core
simulations you find the effective
personality was about
10 the highest so in other words locally
right if you look at what's called gunks
or clicks the click
from a graph you can see which one
interacts with what and then
and then you decompose the entire
product into a sum
of products and and the science so so
then you can use some sort of uh
anova uh functional noven and
so there's a few tricks and also you
have sampling uh
in frequency space for stationary
problems for non-stationary there's
still
hope and so on so i was trying to push
the limit here
there in in guns there's a paper
if you're interested in this physics in
form
uh uh guns that we did
uh also in sisk then there was a 120
dimensions
and then there's a follow-up paper in
super computing
2019 where we simulated the comfort side
the nuclear site at pnl and we used 10
000 dimensions using
guns to do that we use 500
500 generators and i don't remember how
many discriminators but something like
that
okay thanks yeah
i i have a question george um you know
you are um solving very
um illupose problem in in nature like
the inverse problem for example
and um i'm wondering depending on the
you know the hyper parameter for example
or the
the structure of the neural net you know
the number of layers etc
you know does the solute the solution
because the problem is in proposed
and depending on how much data you have
individually trained different neural
net
may give you different solutions of
course they give you different solutions
everything we do we never we never run i
mean
even a standard neural network you never
run it once you're having at least 10
times right
so so so um so that
that's clearly that's why a lot of my
work most recently it's also an
uncertainty
totally if you see some of my papers i i
talk about total uncertainty
quantification not just
data due to data with buyers and
networks but also the network
itself the uncertainty so yeah that's a
big uncertainty and so you have to be
very very careful
and the identifiability issue becomes of
great importance
but that's why regularization is also
important so in some sense the pde and
the parameter spds help you
but sometimes like in this inviscid
problem that i show you
the euler equation we need to do a some
sort of an l1
regularization to uh to get good
solutions and so on
yeah i think okay but but
it's extremely dangerous with this to
run only
one time only one only one time yeah
i got a good answer that's that's yeah
yeah yeah but it's still very empirical
i don't like it it's so empirical but
yeah
yeah yeah understood well i mean the the
problem itself is so
conditioned so it's uh you cannot avoid
that i guess
the coffee i can tell you that the
coffee exams look pretty good actually
for some reason the coffee the coffee
example the
standard the variance was very little
from run to run
oh anyway if you have a lot of data
if you have a lot of data we have 3d
data right from the density the density
gradients
from the selenium photography can give
you that in time and space
uh you can you can actually uh
actually go closer well that's why
that's why pins don't work very well
in in for forward problem they work
great for
invest problems because we have the
optimization because you uncover the
solution somewhere
and then you help the optimization it's
not nothing to do with the
um you know how you know the classical
lux type
stability it's it's more like
helping the the stochastic gradient
descent or the adam and so on to
to to find the um uh
close to minimum to global go close to
global minimum yeah
that makes sense well um if
is there any other other questions if if
there is please speak up
um otherwise i think we are going to
wrap up here
uh sorry george um just to follow up on
what you previously
uh we were talking about with the the
additive kernels and the assist paper uh
but what was the title of that paper
uh uh it has the um
massive uh dimensions or something like
that
massive data set it's about uh
three years maybe old uh
and uh i can find that
paris per dicari is the first author uh
danielle venturi is the second
author okay i know myself
with this trick you come i think you can
uh
identify that yeah yeah all right thank
you
okay wonderful okay
um any other questions
one two three okay well
well let's thank uh the professor katya
uh
because for the wonderful talk and great
work which is very
impactful these days for various
research areas directly relevant to what
we are doing in orange livermore so
let's uh upload thank you so much yeah
thanks
thanks for the opportunities great
questions guys i had a good time thank
you very much for inviting me
i'm happy to uh answer offline just
shoot me an email
a lot of people uh uh contact me so
uh you know if you if you're interested
in if you have a good yeah
i work i like people with data if you
have data i'm happy to work
with people i work for data not money i
say
well thanks very much for hosting me
today take care thank you thank you so
much
all right that concludes the seminar
today and
thank you so much everyone for joining
us next
ddps seminar will be thursday next week
until then
uh have a good day and have a nice
week everyone alright bye